don't suppose to sell cake ghostbusters
hey where's this Peck I'm Walter Peck
sir and I'm here to file a full report
these men are consummate snowball
artists people think they're getting a
sequel when all they're getting is it
the same repackaged film just which is
funny because he has no dick now I'll
say please please please like I know
this thing called laughter oh my god
someone to know about what you do here
oh that's like the one time I wait
you're gonna do the same villain again
just get him just bring it back oh great
oh okay so surreal thoughts and
Ghostbusters - the reason we're doing
this is because we didn't film our our
first viewing of it he wasn't feeling
very well I guess yeah I have like a
super cold yeah so so we're just doing a
real thoughts on this one and I even
looked at the comments on this one yet
so I have no idea of people are like you
know if they want our heads or if
they're just like fuck yeah but yeah
pretty much
I don't care yeah I really know I'm like
I'm so with all the shit that's happened
ghostbusters awaited in the past yeah
it's like I give up nobody's gonna be
happy so I'll just speak my freakin
mouth when this movie came out I mean
must been yours old something like that
and I like dude cuz it's just cool to
see ghosts but I fucking love
Ghostbusters when I was a kid I knew as
the cartoon first and then the movie
imagine seeing it in that order that is
like the coolest goddamn thing the world
us always sees cartoon characters
swearing and smoking get blowjobs from
came out the movie came out in 84 I'm
the older brother and I would have been
5 yeah we didn't really see them but
when the cartoon came don't even know
we're in the States so the cartoon came
out we watched the first season
basically yeah and that's what
that's when our dad showed this the
movie right after we saw we're just not
in the cartoon show yeah we were just
like blown away like this is amazing and
then I'd say wonder that show come out
oh the cartoon I don't know someone
someone knows but so it was like a good
three yeah but maybe three years later
cartoons amazing get really good so it
was like a good three years later when
Ghostbusters 2 came out it was like 1989
I think it was like around Christmas and
I remember seeing it and liking it
yeah but more like into someone yeah I
liked it but I didn't it was not like
see here's the thing this is where it
gets troublesome is if you gave me the
option of watching the cartoon or the
first movie as a kid that was a legit
tough choice yeah
even now that kind of time seen the
cartoon in a while yeah but that was a
legit gleich cuz I loved the movie so
much as a kid but I also loved the
cartoon even though I liked Ghostbusters
too because I was kid and I saw it I
watched the cartoon yeah if you gave me
the choice between the cartoon and ghost
just for you yeah I never watched
Ghostbusters 2 as a kid as much as I
want it wasn't the same episode over and
over that you had different ideas and
different things that happen different
characters come in and stuff you know I
mean the the only thing that legit good
in Ghostbusters - it's the villain which
is kind of a repeat is kind of another
goes here but I mean he looks different
sounds different
yah no she's great I mean he's a
wonderful funny villain and that's
really about how no you know a statue
liberties a little cool you know that's
a total repeat of the more we were
talking about and I was just like
there's four great cuz there was like a
couple of weird things I noticed because
I hadn't seen the film in a while so I'm
like alright let's let's watch again
there were four performances and that
really sort of blew my mind though the
first two are obvious it's peter
McNichol and then the eastern german
wrestler or whatever he is have voiced
by Max von Sydow so Viggo and Janos are
the two best things in the movie
hands down the next one you know who
puts in a really good performance is
Sigourney Weaver because she always puts
in a good performance like even to the
point that in the bathtub scene it's
kind of hilarious as though she saw it
and it's like this cheesy like you know
she's written terribly she went off you
but she's pretty good when the baby is
in the carriage yeah she sells the drama
of it even when like it's so ridiculous
like the the bathtub scene it just makes
me laugh because she said like but it's
like this cheesy and I'm like it's just
so bad some creases like a zombie only
foam and then the other thing that I
remember turning knew and I'm like
here's the weird thing duck who's the
funniest Ghostbuster in this I was
saying Egon and ya know and then I said
I'm like it's Iike but when you think
about the first movie Egon has some
great lines in the first he's not the
funny no he's not the funniest it's you
could argue that either Venkman or Ray
okay particular way they play off each
other but Ray's got those great light
like those great technobabble the naive
yeah like symmetrical book stacking just
like the Berlin mask you know which then
Venkman plays off of by saying you're
right no human being would stack books
like yeah you know so you've got that
but I'm just like you look at this one
and like venkman's 50/50 in the movie
50% of the time he's got some great
lines and it works another fingers at a
time he's like boy what a baby and it's
like what and then the weird thing was
Dan Aykroyd is just not funny in this
movie there's very few scenes where I
ever laugh at a dan Aykroyd like so many
of them they beam so much the
stereotypes the cardboard cutouts of
their original characters where it's
like okay Dan Aykroyd's the hard we got
that so he's 100% little kid heart it's
almost like they were trying to be the
cartoon but it was even tight love you
man dude I believe things have gotten so
bad in the city well you know okay
here's another thing that kind of pisses
me off
Ernie Hudson comes in
that is it even halfway in the first
ghost but I think it's like the last 30
cups yeah it's like the last which is
already kind of weird from a story
structure but it's like he's so he's so
much fun and he's so cool and one he
gave so so he gave it a blue collar
aspect to it that's the one yeah page
that that's him via you know we always
make fun of that he's not in much or
what he is in it is not that good but he
is so goddamn charming yes so freakin
cool way just an image we got utilized
Oh fuckin Kongo what a piece-of-shit
movie that and he's amazing it so smooth
him it's him curry make that movie yeah
and you know here you have him again in
this movie it's like why isn't he with
him and even when he's in those scenes
he's kind of he's like Richard Pryor Wow
like whatever he's a movie with um G
Wilder he's just like oh so New York oh
my dear and the 19 the 18 kill hundreds
of people did you get the number sorry I
missed it yeah like that says one line
I'm just like really but like even like
wave in you know he comes in and saves
the day once by putting out the fire but
that's just kinda it's just like shout
for Winston then he shows up and that's
a scene like yeah a lot like he I don't
know and I just think he does he does
have one more like amazing line like the
sort of line them like damn that one
does steel the movie just it's quiet
once so yeah it's like it so it's just
so under the radar like it's that thing
if you're a kid you missed the
significance of that line but yeah
sleeping with pisses me off that he
wasn't in more of him but again you know
it's one of those things where this was
kind of a thing for a while like in
maybe alone the 80s but especially in
the 90s where sequels were really just
supposed to be a repeat of the first one
you know maybe they did before then too
but especially like in those two decade
it was just expected and there was no
reason why there is no reason to do that
except we have a formula let's do it
again but nobody wanted to see then
that's why people are always I almost
sequels are never as good because they
would just do the same thing yeah well
there's so many opportunities with this
idea the choices they make
even with
in the boundaries of we just have to do
the same film again like made no sense
me and I remember as a kid like 1989 I
would have been 10 maybe 11 depending on
what time of year so it'd have been 10
or 11 I remember sitting there when the
kids like I thought was gonna be he man
and my first thought was like pee man
hey man I was like teach me Ninja
Turtles I but the second thing I thought
is well hey man hey man my dad said
you're full of crap I was just like
sitting there as a ten-year-old like
you're fucking shit yeah like you agree
I was like sitting or going I would have
killed them the Ghostbusters at my
birthday party because we were all kids
and we loved the Ghostbusters and there
was such a weird weird disconnect
between how popular Ghostbusters was as
a property at the time especially the
kids to kids especially don't versus a
movie that literally the kids are just
shitting on the Ghostbusters I remember
as a kid it bothered me I'm like yeah
what I'm like what universe is this
doesn't make sense
this could work if the idea of the movie
was they want to get further away from
kids and they want yeah Gooding and
throwing in the baby doing everything
again make you dad that great like a big
kid himself and everything and you're
just going the exact opposite and
therefore no reason some you know cut
off hands so that's the weird thing they
did everything in this movie to
basically turn it into more of like a
family budget oh you know Bill Murray
literally like in the commentary for the
original movie they say our hero the con
artist like his first scene is literally
him hitting on some fucking student like
you know and like completely just being
a total con in the whole movie to now
like oh no it's like he's good be
families good play with the baby you
know I should have been your father and
then and this and that and then they of
the Ghostbusters in the original film
it's an 80s movie that is a gritty
eighties movie they are chain-smoking
drinking out of flasks getting BJ's from
ghosts like it it's like guardians of
the galaxy where it's like yeah kids no
doubt like this but it's still clearly
it's adults doing adult things in a
weirdly kiddush world where the silly
said of this is this is what happens
when you have a property that was not
meant to be a kid's property that gets
latched onto accidentally by kids and
when they realize that that had happened
this is popular with kids you know that
that doomed Ghostbusters that spelled
the end of it at least as a movie
franchise because in Ghostbusters - they
never drink they never smoke they hardly
swear by Wyatt found 1/3 the other ones
out there there's one swear where and
there's there's I dad you find two quick
little bits of smoky one is a pipe which
okay might as well not count but the
other is one that when they're doing the
Statue of Liberty when they're putting
the slime everywhere it's a he has a
cigar for like a minute and it's almost
like and see adults that's more like
shit done that in the review when it's
like mortal I don't see where you're I'm
sure head Jeanine go week out what I'm
sorry this is popped about that what is
just popped that's more like a New
Year's thing just like you smoke the
cigar happy new year like yeah but no
they're like Shane smoking in the
original man um it was us but that's the
weird thing so they did everything to
turn this basically into a kids movie
and then randomly their severed heads
like in the subway scene and I remember
as a kid that terrified me Mike what the
hell but the rest of the movie didn't
feel that way there are more like to me
there are more scary scenes that like
got me in the first movie yeah kid then
there really were in the second one yeah
yeah yeah oh she's the nanny is creepy
as fuck but it's it doesn't compare to
like Dana Barrett being dragged into the
ocean that's fine cool dogs yeah or the
Zul dogs as much as some of those
effects don't hold up the stop-motion
overall though the Zul dog puppets the
them like live exit yeah no they're
creepy yeah and there's not really much
in this movie that's like that what no
and here's yeah you know we were talking
about how much we like the villains and
the reason they work is he have one
who's really funny
yeah Viviana is very funny on the other
plays it's straight yeah yeah
Viggo is lit
intimidating and I really like yet if
you read the history of that actor oh
that dudes fucked up oh my god like that
the read ahead of the movie is way
scarier is an adult cuz if you read
about that guy's back history I'm just
like oh my god he really is vegan okay
yeah fucking monster and when he does
that like sneer like what he's like
looking at her it's like you know I was
thinking like a mother for the town this
is just like very well oh and I'm just
like I'm like that's this dude's rape
face I have a God like that's probably
what it looked like it said don't look
it up unless you want be like yeah yeah
you won't watch the movie the say yeah
but like when he gets that like creepy
lusty face I'm just like oh god but but
I mean even even with that taken out the
character is very intimidating and again
even though the four or not is funny
there's still it's just cool seeing them
it is kind of a nostalgia of it and I
think that might be why some people
still look on the movie kind of finally
because they do remember growing up
liking it and it is still the for guys
and there is still a bit of a creep
factor to it you know I think that's why
some people rank well that's still
ghostbusters that's still it's like but
it's it's almost too much Ghostbusters
cuz there's too much repeating and it's
like why not expand this world and
really do some voice remember when we
were like watching it when the courtroom
scene came up I just turned you and I
was just like why didn't they start the
movie here and you let go you you had
this moment and you just went oh my god
but kept falling into place and cuz we
were saying that not the reason for this
movie but legit you know being sued for
Gozer and stuff like that everything
else in the movie you can even keep the
plot kind of the same with some of the
repeat you would just get rid of like
one third maybe the like you know yeah
like one third of the bullshit and just
hop right into it you have an amazing
intro with all of this and it's
immediately showing hey we're not just
doing the first one again we're gonna
you know we're starting you up
here they are busting ghosts were
getting right into the shit instead just
slowly building up doing of why doing
the first time over again it makes no
sense not because my favorite is Jeanine
never gets an intro did you notice that
how just randomly decide yes we're bad
she's a cartoon Karen I know she's a
cartoon character the cartoon did her
better than this movie yeah well that's
the thing in the first one she's a real
human being yeah like you know she tries
to get more money she's like sick of
putting up with Venkman shit quick
better job this one he's gotta crush
them again yeah but this she's like
nerded her up in like a Revenge of the
Nerds kinda like way along and then they
put her together with Tully come on wait
he had some laughs as the lawyer even Oh
that'd be his best bitch yeah his best
bits pretty good dog it may help me
thank thank you it was short but
pointless yeah I really got my degree in
the night school that's okay Louis cuz
we were arrested at night but yeah so
they did that but like so many things
make no sense because the earliest this
film could have taken place is
Thanksgiving I know we talked about how
Christmas invades everything in 1989 the
earliest you start seeing Christmas
decorations is Thanksgiving weekend so
I'm like that's the earliest it can be
so basically we've gone from there
pretty much out of business they're
doing birthday parties they're running
some other bookstore on the side Egan's
working maybe for a university venkman's
got some stupid cable access show we
never see their headquarters not once
before they basically open back up so
they've got all this going and then
before New Year's so in six weeks time
they investigate the slime they go to
the court case a court case that alone
would probably take weeks to put
together then they go back in business
somehow get Janine back like was she
working for them the whole time somehow
get the fuck what she was doing was
doing stuff yeah I thought a funny thing
would be like if they're getting like
sued by basically everybody for the
Gozer stuff if like after the intro
credits like she's just like oh oh
you've got one oh yeah that's great
cuz I totally need the job cuz these
guys are going nowhere and she's like
ready to walk ya cuz like they've got no
money but now she just shows up like
randomly and I'm just like so all this
happened and then they do the commercial
with free balloons or that which looks
stupid I'm just like and basically
you're back on top of the world in six
weeks
what well no okay on top see here's the
thing cuz that's when you have to do it
all over again it just the first film is
like doesn't make a whole lot of sense
he because it's like well how does what
was Slimer originally before he died I
mean it's like there's a budget that
meets like it's kid logic so even if
even if you want to go by that reasoning
you know okay well we can say okay kid
kind of kids movie kind of weird
whatever why do we want to see all about
it yeah but it does all this it makes
stupid mistakes like that it makes no
sense and it contributes nothing to the
movie it's like why would you do it all
over again well I like a beginner hater
and Dana breaking up and like honestly I
know like there's this whole thing where
people are like trying to be like Oh
Venkman is a misogynist and this and
that it's no shit but that was the point
he's a con artist in the first movie
what are y'all dense but but he's also
but is this charm to it yeah but when
you see it a second time going after his
old flame that's already been gone for
years I'm just like it's actually
creepier and Ghostbusters - yeah I'm
sorry it's singles all the time yeah and
she's like well I guess I'm into it
again now and I'm just like this makes
no sense to do it all over again the
whole here we go again
yeah um like I said I think the biggest
thing that was really shocking about why
this film is the way it is is that yet
you did have and maybe because people I
can't cartoons kids who cares but
there's so much effort and creativity
and imaginative writing was put into
that cartoon him really just opened up
this world and have fun with it there is
the groundbreaking or anything but it
really has every photo season or every
other plot of that cartoon show would
have made a better plot for guys but
yeah so anything goes so then you got
the people who originated this idea come
along dan Acker and I guess said that
the original Ghostbusters script prima
start out how this one they washing it
like there's almost like an OCD part of
them that's like oh good I can do this
cuz I always wanted to do this and you
really want to completely missing the
point now that no kid wanted to see that
yeah so and I mean be honest with
yourself if you're like one of those I
saw this as a kid it's like the movie is
that what you really wanted to see
though or did you just like because of
that Ghostbusters written on it well and
I feel like there's not same camp I'm
like I like the movie but it's nostalgic
I mean I'm not claiming it's a good
movie cuz it's not I I think that ok the
main reason now I think like cuz this
started to get kind of a everyone hated
it when it came out then I started to
get a resurgence I think particularly
with the reboot coming out cuz every
they just want to hate that more so they
could say the original two were great
that second one was shit but and by but
people yeah but people are seeing it
more because now when people do sequels
if it does repeat people don't like that
they're like well why do I want to see
the same thing again because movies like
the Marvel movies and some of these
superhero movies and the Evil Dead
movies or they're doing very weird
they're changing the style and the tone
and everything they're really trying to
this different stuff and their sequels
uh you know and people are want that
they want to see something really
different so then when they go back and
they're like oh well compared to now
when they do sequels they do really
out-of-the-box thinking stuff and really
advance the story or just do something
totally new why why did I like this one
where they were just doing the exact
same thing and it makes no sense like
whatsoever it's not even fun to see them
go through all this stuff again and
let's let's bring up the third movie or
soft reboot to remake er we don't even
know what it's a call it's a call to
answer the call because sometimes I see
if there sometimes I don't like I don't
even know if it's like is it just
Ghostbusters 2016 psychosis answer the
call like say so did not know it comes
why but-- remake rehash it's a it's a
medium reboot whatever or whatever you
want to call it what made the first
movie fun particularly for kids like the
80s or we grew up with it is the fact
that you felt like you were getting away
with something by watching it because it
was scary there was not the most in
volume you have a queef joke yeah but it
was dark it was gritty they were
chain-smoking they were drinking we're
getting BJ's they're like
it's an adult movie I don't care what
you say it's an adult comedy that kids
happen to latch on know that has a lot
of kid elements that makes it even more
awesome yeah feels beautifully immature
what your gritty but immature work
that's the second movie was they
repeated everything and then all of the
things that we thought were fun as kids
because we felt like we were getting
away with something they sucked out of
it I was talking to Brad Jones about
this and his point I think is very legit
he calls it one of the first 90s movies
and it's that transition between 80s
into 90s films where we had basically
all the personality and the fun of the
eighties just kind of sucked down it's
like now we we got to make it
family-friendly and colorful and bright
in this if they ninja turtles tune it
yeah and that's another film that did
the same thing you looking into turtles
one and then you look at Ninja Turtles 2
it's like well we got a right down to a
Vanilla Ice suck although like dirty
little things that we enjoyed about the
first one out of it and make it
family-friendly and then when they do
the reboot they're like well we have to
have this ready for kids we have to man
this is what bothers me when people try
to talk about how this one with Melissa
McCarthy and the queef jokes Despero
into the franchise did you sit through
the second film like did you actually
watch that film with your eyes wide open
because I think the third film is worse
than the second one absolutely it's
tough I Do's that third film is merely
the logical conclusion of everything the
second film started that's all it is
it's everything that second film tried
to do they took it basically to its
logical conclusion to the end of the
road as far as you can take it and that
was the third film it's bright it's
colorful we can't have dark red slime
know like and Ghostbusters super gotta
have the shampoo looking pink slime you
know it can't look really super creepy
that that reminds it guy I told you I
didn't bring this up when I first saw
the trailer for ghostbusters - I thought
that was blood we all did I was
cuz again it's like okay this is gonna
be dark this is gonna be gritty this is
gonna be just like the first one it's
like it was too much like the first one
except all the cool stuff was taken out
like that being blood like how amazing
would that be if that was just like
shining style blue river a blood blood
oozing up everywhere people step in the
blood we can cover in the blood it just
would have up to the grittiness so much
and it just would have been so much more
like a cool creepy idea but it's like no
it's it's lime and it's like yes when I
when I think of the third film I think
of a bright colorful movie aimed more at
kids with a lot of the scares removed
the goofiness level up not a lot of
drinking not a lot of smoking a lot of
the sex is just kind of only inferred if
even that and on top of that all of the
characters are turned into basically
kind of one-dimensional cartoon
characters gee where did any of that
start yeah
like it literally Ghostbusters 2 started
all of this and I say this am i dying
they ghostbusters 2 killed the franchise
yeah that's what did it this film is
merely this film is the result of the
cancer that started with ghostbusters 2
but now now ok Ghostbusters 3 is the
lifeless body but now here's the real
budget again this is the Ghostbusters
reboot handsome house very good would we
want what would we prefer the reboot or
Ghostbusters 3 with aging none of them
want to be there goes bust it's that the
kingdom of the cone of skull of
ghostbusters if you all know already
they wanted they were just so ready we
work together so an actual throw our
hate at it and when they couldn't throw
an actual Ghostbusters 3 with the
original cast would have been awful yeah
they already proved they are they
already were showing where they wanted
to go with this and Ghostbusters 2 yeah
and I'm supposed to believe that all of
a sudden are gonna look at Ghostbusters
see me like you know what we've learned
from all of our mistakes you can and you
can blame Bill Murray for it he didn't
want to do it and I completely agree
with him he's like yeah movies like I
did one sequel was ghostbusters 2 and it
was awful and you look at his
performance you could just tell that
he's just not into it is like yeah
baby I guess yeah you know and I'm
saying to myself you know could
Ghostbusters 3 work if they got all the
people you met payroll dreams so still
alive that they go in chase here for
Venus computer-generated goes to begun
voiced by Maurice LaMarche that's what
they would have done um but I was saying
you know could that in any way be good
and the only thing I thinking like you
meant to have one hell of a writer one
hell of a director and you know really
like Oscar caliber performance it was
not gonna be I go right now age cuz I
ever wait I did it Ghostbusters three
was called evolution yeah but but I mean
like yet you would just have to have the
best of the best
on this movie in order for it to work
and it's impossible I guess it is highly
unlikely it's passed what happen there
was men in black 3 which was actually a
good movie
yeah but I'm not sitting here going that
Oh men in black 3 was the most amazing
movie ever made
yeah like so it's it was definitely good
the seed men and black - sucked
no I feel like minimize good but I'm
just like that like what I'm not sure is
worth it to get it yeah you have to do
something like Cobra Kai like haven't
work on a completely different level
just a whole new kind of comedy kind of
drama kind of weirdness no that
heaviness dark grittiness Ben was a very
strange let's which can happen but it's
really really really unlike and that's
what disappointed me most of all about
answer the call is the way it tried to
do something slightly new well
absolutely nothing new at the exact same
time let's bring all the original casts
back whatsoever man cameos let's still
make it kind of a going into business
story I'm a big you know let's take all
the cool things that could have been
brought to this when you bring on a
bunch of SNL alum you got Melissa
McCarthy you got Paul Feig directing it
now let's remove any overt sexual
references smoking drinking all the fun
there are rated comedies funny let's
move all of that and water it down and
make it another kits film like
ghostbusters to only like on you know
some sort of sugar rush yeah you know
and like that's why it sucks but when I
look at it it's like
who started it who set them down this
pan that path started in 1989 I'll say
the one thing about because here's the
thing when comparing like I do go back
and forth I'm like well okay what's
which one's worse you know the reboot or
ghostbusters 2 and like again if the
repeat of ghostbusters 2 really pisses
me off but I mean the one thing that's
really missing in the reboot is that the
second one like I said there was still a
little bit of that creep factor it was
kind of cartoony but it was there you
would add the kapitaen answer you would
have this creepy guy in like this Mary
Poppins out to go and the eyes would
glow red it's just like little is just
kind of early and uncomfortable and
stuff like that where the other one is
just 100% cartoon go it's like there's
nothing legit creepy about it I think
that bothers me less about the third one
and I think we said this when we were
talking about it's just it's such a
non-event yeah it's so like mostly
harmless in the way that like you could
just pretend this didn't exist what
bothered me more about too is
particularly at the time as we were so
waiting for that yeah like as kids we
had the cartoon now we had the original
with that it's such a bigger
disappointment this one it's just like
nobody's saying Ghostbusters is at their
height right now like it was just you
could just see it for the cheap
marketing ploy it was all people in
there for it's it's just like why makes
such a huge deal out of something that
you're just like whatever in one ear out
the other all people wanted and I even
people just super diehard fans it was
this to see them get back together do
Ghostbusters three so they can see them
together and then instantly hate it you
know I mean it that's what they wanted
to see that's what would happen yeah but
no nobody said I really wanted to see
this reboot and come back and because so
you're already going to something nobody
really wants to see so if you're gonna
do you really got to do something really
different or really awesome and it
wasn't enough of either of them the only
the only thing I wanted to see honestly
what's another Ghostbusters cartoon at
this point because I'm like you could
take your time you could do it you could
get a season one you could get some
story arcs goings you could do it either
with all women or with the original
cares you can do whatever you want
but I felt like that's probably the best
medium where you can actually do
something with it is the cuz I've only
seen bits and pieces just from the title
I'm guessing it's
good but I haven't seen so I shouldn't
say it's extreme Ghostbusters any good
okay the last time I saw odd is when it
actually ran and I had it through two
episodes and never looked back so I'm
gonna say at the time I thought no but I
even looked at it say yeah it's one of
those things where it's like I'm looking
at it and it's like I think like a lot
of people like you wanna put a do in a
wheelchair fine but he seemed to have no
personality outside of he's the
wheelchair guy and that's what it seemed
like like oh he's oh that guy he's the
black guy that's the wheelchair guy the
woman probably God you know and that no
the problem with the nineties it looks
like a very nothing no and that's show
that's the problem with another problem
with the 90s so very nineties yeah it's
very just token-based we need the one
token character of everything we can
think of throw them together it's the
Captain Planet concept but if you want
okay if you're gonna do that
I don't care make them interesting make
them interesting outside of their skin
color their gender their you know
disability whatever maybe we need to
have a character beyond that how about
this and this is something I think that
the bits that we saw at least I mean I
feel like that's what we saw on the show
and I don't remember being like hugely
insulted just remember being like
nothing how about this I haven't seen
the whole show this is something that I
think creators now the not the studio
led ones with the creators that are kind
of coming up with their own stuff and
then they end up selling it to various
cartoon studios is uh far more keenly
aware of instead of trying to throw all
of it into one show why don't you take
something you know so if you want to
show about a kid in a wheelchair you
make a show about a kid in the
wheelchair if you you want to show
dealing with the black experience you
make that if you want to show dealing
with girl powers you instead of just
trying to shoehorn everything into one
single show and that was something that
bugged me a bit about the 90s it was
only the they always felt like a we got
to do it in one show like every single
thing and just cram it in there it's
like well why don't you take one of
those things and explore it in depth and
if you all make enough cartoon shows and
think like that you can have a ton of
different shows that tackle every
issue and race creed gender religion
whatever yeah I mean for me it's like I
I never cared where I go no I never
cared what they were as long as they
just they have personalities like you
know I don't care the dudes in a
wheelchair what's he like you know I
don't care if there's a black dude there
what's he like I don't care that's a
woman what she like you know it's like
that's the she I'm gonna have to write a
character yeah you know you have to
write beyond you know the token thing
pisses me off about Winston it's like in
the movies you know she was becoming
more than the token but then be like not
let's put you back in there come on come
on our movie it's just like no come on
it's Ernie Hudson and he's so cool
because he's the only one to that is not
the scientist the con artist then
they're like so like it's an interesting
position to be in to be the guy that's
like this is a job I turn the blaster on
and I do this and then you have to work
with these three kind of you know
weirdos well hey they never really
explore it that much it's like a subtext
it's there but they never dive much into
it because it's always gonna be well
it's got to be the main three doing
something and it's like it's a shame
yeah particularly when it's already else
yeah and he's so cool so yeah but that's
the thing like when we watch things like
Steven universe or other shows like
that's what I like about it's like okay
it hasn't crammed everything that it's
focusing on certain things you know you
don't need to cram every single thing
now Steven universe actually is huge
enough of a show that it actually does
cram a lot in but I never feel when I
watch I feel like okay for the most part
these are characters I feel like well we
need to shove this in there MF s is a
short overweight one guy is this huge
you know tall black wine and he got the
little boy who's almost like the token
boy in the show and say you had
different people different sides above
well my characters yeah I'm like no guy
no the cool one who's very stoic and
straight bait doesn't catch on to humor
much amethyst is the goof off and she's
gonna you know break the rules and sub
pearl is the one who's always uptight
and wants everything this is different I
see them as real characters and I don't
see them as points on the chart yeah in
a boardroom in Hollywood where well the
chart says we need to like you know it's
like somebody thought how do we make
these characters interesting first now
it's ironic because we're
we're pointing this out about a show we
have not seen much again I mean like psy
and when we did see when you drag this
down here no no it's like but that but
that's what I remember - yeah I've only
said I only know if I've seen a full
episode just seemed bits and pieces of
it I'm just looking as I said like the
dark ages
oh we know yeah we were talking about so
even then when there was no real demand
for it they brought this show back and I
I don't say I'll say enough I don't
think it did well I think - at the time
like and this may play into it I was
kind of going through that phaser he's
gonna kind of cartoon now yeah I was
like hitting high school and I'm just
like and this just isn't for me so maybe
if I watched it again I wouldn't be that
bad but I can't I can't say positive but
I'm just saying that that was a problem
I saw no I legit yeah are we missing out
on a good show around like snowy choice
stereotypical 90s what you think it is
yeah because I don't
I always forget it apart from if it
wasn't that that was just a general
problem I saw in the 90s yeah yeah I
feel like writing in cartoons for the
most was gun a lot better yes and almost
like lessons were learned like you know
this is just a bunch of chart guys just
telling us what we want and then people
writing shows now grew up with those
shows and they got sick of it they're
like I don't want to see that I'm fine
having people you know wheelchairs and
different colors and stuff it's just I
want them to be interesting people so
that's what they went and did and
cartoon shows are a lot better I think
because same thing with ghostbusters two
people saw that sequin said no I don't
want my sequel to be like I want to be
different I want do new shit so the
other thing about Ghostbusters - that
bothered me was they're just they got
the firehouse back just boom instantly
they get it back and you know there it
is I mean maybe they never lost it but
they never explained how they were able
to hold on do it if they have five years
they somehow held on oh yeah but I there
was something about the tech in the
first one that was super cool you guys
we never see the containment unit in
this film hmm not once they didn't even
build a mock-up of it you never see the
containment unit and the only new tech
we get there's a dancing toaster
yeah it's just the sliced up and Jen the
slime guns are the slime guns which I'm
just like it's not it struck me as such
an it's a Nickelodeon toy yeah like it
struck me as like like they were trying
to cash in on like the Nickelodeon slime
thing that was starting to you know get
right down to there like haha so we
didn't explain more yeah but then they
changed it to pink yeah because
everybody will think they microwave
slime air and they're just it's very
telling to me when the coolest piece of
tech the two coolest pieces of tech in
the movie are Anessa NES advantage the
banana it's it and the spectrometer or
whatever they called it that analyzed
the paintings I just remember as a kid I
was like this boo-ki that's cool like
you take a picture but then you run it
through this special thing and then you
get scary images so you know like that
so that's our thoughts man uh I don't
know what people think of this but let
us know what you think the extreme kills
play should we watch it should we not
that's about it see you later
take care
you